Today he is going to talk a little about
accessibility accessibility although you
eat that but before starting to talk about
accessibility I want to talk a
little about disabilities and the
word disability is this word
is what is called impro la serna or
a term  general that it is a word or
a phrase that covers a great variety
of concepts for example the word
hands this word includes all kinds of
birds hummingbirds achievements eagles etc.
using this type of terms has
certain problems and is mostly
based on how our work  brain
the principle of
linguistic relativity tells us that the way
we think about the world is
directly influenced by the language
we use to execute it, we
will also have to abstract and generalize
depending on our experiences
but this is not a problem
when we talk about birds  or about things
but when we start talking about
people about social issues of gender
and we are going to start to see certain
problems and this is what I think
happens with the word disabilities
when I use this word each one of
us thinks of something different but
At the same time many many others
think the same
and this can be someone in a
wheelchair or a blind person the
interpretation of these words
will always be different depending
on the person you are listening to and the
reason why will fall there.  It is so
complicated to establish a definition
for it
a few years ago a glossary was created with
new values ​​and translations for
mother languages ​​I died from Polynesia that
is found from now on within these
words are the hollow words for me
it produces I think but translating into Spanish
means disabled  the definition of
them is great means to have strength and to
have abilities of another type
this word was specifically created
with the trained communities and
emphasizes the gain and strength of
ability
the idea of ​​creating this name I will know
was to be able to use words that do not have a
negative judgment  and that they are more inclusive
because as we all know the words
have these steps and the word
disabled has also been used in
many negative contexts, which
should not be
if we go to the dictionary, it tells us
that disability is a restriction,
absence of the ability to perform  an
activity within the range that is
considered normal but is normal in this
definition we are basing ourselves on the
interpretation of what is normal something
that in one society or culture is
considered normal
is not necessarily so in another and on the other
hand on many occasions  it is also
associated with diseases when in
reality it is much more expensive
the world health organization
tells us that disabilities include
impairments that are problems in the
function or structure of the body of
people
restrictions in participation in
day-to-day situations for example  and
limitations in the activity that are
difficult to find when finding an
activity or an action
as we see it is a bit difficult to make only
one meaning for this word but we
can also see it as the
discrepancy between the abilities of
a person and their environment
this makes us see a  little and we can
say that inaccessible environments create
disabilities and this is where the
concept of accessibility comes in, which is
accessibility we can say in the
possibility of access but the principle
of accessibility seeks to eliminate or
reduce the barriers that hinder
the rights of the disabled without
no matter what we are talking about, whether it
is in spaces, things, information,
etc., in the context of water, we can
say that being accessible is making your
product available to
anyone, no matter how they use it,
we are here to offer another option by
kate tinming in accessibility  hands of
and it is quite tied to the axes of
universal design
because we have to do this with what I
already told you we put the coins and if you
ask me and they would do it because it is the right thing to do
but unfortunately this is not
enough for many if it were it
probably would not be
Talking to you about this here in our engine
was completely different but it may
take a while, that's what is happening. I
think we have to give a little more
to issues of the past
because the marm in which we live is
constantly changing to the point where
we can say that  the constant is
change
many years ago we needed a whole
room to have a computer and
now we can carry it on our wrist
before the web looked like this links and text
more nothing and now it looks more or less like this
cookies banners allers to post a
lot of  things and technology have
changed the web has evolved to the
point that the web is now part of
our day to day
apply for work do our
taxes learn new things
buy etc. and now in these
times of pandemic the web has
become  a super
indispensable tool for many people
then we can say that if all this
time we managed to increase the reach of
internet technology but at the same
time we have also managed to make it
super confusing and inaccessible and not very
welcoming to people
as evans mentioned in his analysis of
web accessibility email which is a
non-profit organization and they
have provided solutions for
ge accessibility in 1999 in 2010 and
more they organized an assessment
against the violation of the ampas and most
popular as a sample of a million
pages as  they did this they used a
tool called web this tool
detects problems in the pages that
are not aligned with
established accessibility standards it simply
compares with the standards and I think that
this does not work or this does work but
as all tools have their
disadvantages since not all those
accessibility problems can be
detected automatically only about 25%
and this tells us a lot
about this number
this is the number of errors it
will find almost 60 million
and this is an average of 56 points 6
errors per page and we take a second
to understand the  gravity of this camera
that means that 97 plus 97% of
the pages had to appear and these
are pages like instagram
facebook for verbs reuters
stanford and many more images that
means that they are social networks
news sites universities
etc. sounds quite important  no
but why is this happening as
i mentioned earlier that language and
the way we speak is reflected
in how we interpret things i also
think we reflect our
experiences in what we create there is
this image of how to use a
computer of how we navigate  on the
internet we have the hands to use the
keyboard and the mouse we have a list with
the ability to extinguish all the
small details that we suffer from
values ​​and there is absolutely nothing in
our surroundings that interrupt us
not because it doesn't but for some
reason the  most of what we do is
geared towards this vision and this version
one person
at some point in our lives
will experience a disability each
of us experiences the web in a
different way some people have
trouble seeing certain colors
other people have trouble using
their hands or experience pain that does not
allow us to use their hands for a long
time
have only one arm available while
carrying their children there are millions upon
millions of examples and mining of how to
interact with the web and our environment
but nevertheless accessibility tends
to  be forgotten or now we leave it
to the last we were waiting for someone to
complain to see if we don't care
because many times it is also a lack of
information but we already know that it is
important that we can do how
we do this in my opinion we all have
something to contribute
when we talk about accessibility no
matter if the designer developer
tester is in the business area everyone
anything different we can all
collaborate so now we are going to see a
bit how to improve certain things that
cause the most bugs and here we
are helping you when it is  let's do
my first advice let's go back to basics
every day a super new framework comes out
that is going to change our lives and
a new technology that is going to make everything
easier but trying to keep up
with all this we will also have to
forget as much  basic and it never hurts to
review concepts that we have taken for
granted so the first thing we are going to
do is html html should be
semantic and structured means
this means use the
right tag in the right place we have a
lot of accessible tags airlines
art  and things there are buttons and posts and many
more
all these tags and in their
meaning and their behavior somewhat
good assistive technologies use what
is called the
accessibility tree to generate this the
browser takes the dome and modifies it in
a way that is  useful for all these
technologies it can have less
information or it can have less nodes
because there are some things that are there that are
just visual ie
basically that the
accessibility tree is a subset of the tav
and all this is achieved because the 'top
ten' in meaning  semantic uses
html
the native html elements work
well because their behavior has been
established and is predictable when we
use for example the a sancor tag
the browser knows that they are lic
so when we write our
html we have to make sure that we
are using the  tools that
we have at hand because in many cases
it is enough we take the classic example
of the diff if we try to make a button
as a diff the screen reader has
assistive technology it has no way
of knowing where it is what it is or what it does
because it doesn't even  we can access it
with the keyboard if we do not assign index to it
or if we do not develop the
correct behavior for this
element when we inspect the
text we can see that there is not much
information
kennedy that is all
the user knows therefore do exactly that
amount of information that is nothing but
on the other hand when we use a button the
browser knows it is a roll poster it knows
where it is and it knows what is there de facto it
knows it means that we can do it
wrong keyboard and it has a content that is
face nose and  All this information
can be communicated to the user, therefore he is
spartan in his work, deciding what
are the correct tags to put in
our html and if we are creating an
element never seen before where the
available tags none of the
available tags are there
but you have  Keep in mind that it
has to be accessible and that you have to
test all the necessary roles and behaviors
for it to work
correctly.
When we talk about putting ourselves
in the right place, we refer more to
the structure because the
navigation order and we give it  it is determined
by the code it is theory to be logical and it
should be intuitive in the study
carried out it was found that more than 300,000
of the homepage had problems with
jumping genes there were no certain holdings
for example and with the head in there are certain
rules for example we always have  that
having a chibola the good h writes you
on the page as it is and should be
similar to the title and should only be verona
in the rest of the genes if we see them
as a kind of index they should
represent the different
internal levels on the page without  skip that is
to say the evils and bonuses for che 2 and we
find it night 5 grabbing at the end
because it is so important because thank you very much
genes are the
entry point of people who use
write kings tamez they use us to
get an idea of ​​​​what  It is about what
is on our page and when they
are not, they can be confused.
In the case of the index, it should be used
with care because it can be good or
quite bad. The top index helps us to
remove or give focus
to the elements, for example, we need
mount flight index or any
number greater than 1
this is defining a specific order
and is almost always a good way
we don't want to play with this because it will
take elements out of the normal order of
navigation in the case of using the
upholsterer it allows us to continue  the focus
on the keyboard does not change the order which
is in the order of the navigation but it does not
change it does not have me where it is written
but we have to make it last also
the behavior when it is
focused is with the keyboard it is according to
what  For example, it would make the
enter and space keys interact
correctly,
just as it happens when we click on it, and in
the event that we put a
less good tap index, this allows certain
elements to receive focus
by law but not by the  keyboard in
general we can say that an element
with any value greater than or equal to 1
will receive the focus before the
elements that do not have this index or that
the value to 0
in the case of the order of the order of the
elements there this can change  a css
there are many times that we use that efe to
change the order if an absolute position element
we illuminate above the
defendant but where we want and this
can be quite confusing because there are
people who use spring networks but
still rely visually on the
page then when using  the skin
ride the screen reader will read what
is found in the order it found it
but what the user is seeing is
something else because with ccs we change it
so we have to be careful with
this type of thing and here we are
helping when we maintain  our
semantic and structured html to all the
people who use assistive technologies
or gangs is that the risk
of all this was born in the focus the focus is
basically determines where the
events go the keyboard at any time
some elements have
default focus or fewer inputs  or the
other four do not have any type of focus
as we gave them by the fans and a
simple way to determine if we need a
focus is to ask ourselves can we
interact with this element if the
answer is yes then we need to
provide funds we needed to provide the
behavior so that they can be  make
be with the keyboard what this looks like
when we have a tax is
usually seen as a
tender and one of the most
common errors that can be found is
to remove this car in car and not in if that
is this line that appears around
the  elements we tend to remove it
because it waits because it doesn't match our
design etc. I don't like it bye for
this it's an error because when we remove it
we eliminate the visual indication for
users who use keyboards
at other times if we leave it it's
as it is it's not  enough
because the contrast is not
enough it can make the
background color of our page hide it except it
happens we are given the possibility of
removing it and they also give us the
possibility of accommodating the we have
these four properties that are the
color is the style
the  width and the loser that measures what is the
distance that is on the edge of the
element and with this we can accommodate the
to make it shine and make it
look like the design that we have
without having to hide it and here we
are talking when we do this to
all people who use the keyboard
like most mostly the keyboard someone
for example with permanent paralysis a
person with wrist problems who
can only use the keyboard because the
place is more than cause
another very important topic on the web
is the color and the  contrast when
creating products with
diversity in mind whether they are digital or not the
choice of colors is quite
important color can communicate
brand identity help
users understand information and many
other things but not everyone
perceives the  colors in the way
users including those with
disabilities need to be able to perceive
the content of the page
regardless of the color that zeroes it
doesn't matter if we have the most
beautiful design we've ever created
if people can't see it
then it doesn't serve us in the  case of
contrast when we talk about contrast
we refer to the difference and
luminance or color that makes an
object or the representation of this
object on the screen 6 singles in the
case of things in the real world it is
basically the difference between color
lighting and  the things that surround it and
in the case of the screen we can say
that it is the difference between the background and what
is already text images etc. an
example of how gold affects us
we have this image is an image with
the entire spectrum of colors yes
we apply a simulation of the filter for
someone who has a lack of
sensitivity to blue color that in this
way many colors disappear there
is only red and a little bit of green and this in
the case that we apply something for
sensitivity to red color that is to say a
person is that they cannot receive this
red reader it looks completely
different now we only see yellow or
blue
so if we are trying to communicate
information to the user using a
single color may this information
cannot be communicated correctly
in the case of the drink they have the
color my  friend and mouche just
add a texture on top of the books
that have classes little cards without changing
the color just add the texture and
this helps people who can't
tell your colors
play two ways identify what level
qatar has
in the case of contrast  here we have the
page of the new york times with images
with certain titles of the article olivos
and when we apply a filter that
simulates how things go people
with low contrast sensitivity see
this way it is difficult to read what
the images say no  they look so
clear and this is quite common for
example seniors who
may have trouble trying to read
this
the content we have on our
page is very important and we have to
make sure that this content can
be appreciated also under different
conditions  lighting sunlight the
brightness that reacts on the screen
etc. and make sure that our
page is legible and readable for everyone
when we talk about color contrast we
also refer to the color
we have the color of the text in this case
and the color of the background the  The
accessibility stands have three types:
double a and triple a, in its
triple a, the strictest of all. In
this case, it is a tool
called a square that measures the contrast
between two colors and the one on top passes it.
it is going in stricter because the
contrast that it has is 7.21 and the
work is failing so this
means that the part of the colors
below if we try to use them in
our pages may have
difficulties for someone account of
difficulties to read this these
tools  and many other links are
the team that is at the end of the week
the nations in the case of the text and the
content with a role it is also super
important most of the things
we read that we see in the text
all have the so we read in the
same good level we all have the
same ability to understand the
content even when it is presented
in a clear and simple way
reading memory disorders
attention deficit disorders and other
conditions affect
cognitive processes in the brain and can affect
the ability of a  person to
benefit from the content the text what
can we do in this case we
should consider a
simple language no this I mean
putting the information in a logical order
where the most important details
first adapt your language to the
audience and the context in which  que estás
provides definitions for not-
so-common words and for abbreviations
try to be as literal as possible
because some people with
cognitive disabilities also have
difficulty distinguishing
literal meaning and
implied meaning meaning sarcasm or
parody can be quite  confusing
for some
in the case of fonts using
very small fonts obviously makes everything
difficult to read but using the
correct font is also super important in
this case it is recommended to use
sun series type fonts which are the ones that sleepers do not
have at the end of  the
letters so that they are much easier
to read and write paragraphs try to
keep them
short and not write a super paragraph of
arguís and a lot that can also be
difficult to read and for example if a
user needs to zoom in many
people are even  400
percent in the pages the space of the
text would not change all the
information must be present and in the
case of the icons when we use for
example icons in the form of fonts and
someone for example who uses their own
font because it is better for it is  reading
with this font replaces the font of
our page and the icons on the leg
so you have to be careful when
using icons as fonts so it is
recommended to pose with the best one like that
and we would also avoid
context images but I for example the skin
readers have no way to read the
text inside the image and if necessary
then try an alternative that
could be the tour
in the case of the media I mean
audio videos and things like podcasts
etc. in this case if we have this
type of content in  our page
we should provide subtitles and
transcripts in the case of
subtitles we have captions which is
quite similar to transcripts
because they are in the same language of the video
when the subtitles can also be
in other languages ​​this is super useful for
people who are deaf who have
certain difficulties to listen but
also to help people who
process written information better it is
very common nowadays to find ourselves on
social networks or on any page that
we need videos and the step that they
reproduce automatically than by letting
the videos and the a's be  in auto
place we can cause discomfort to
many people for people with
cognitive disorders it can be a
distraction from the main content for
people with photosensitive epilepsy
it can increase the risk of
seizures or even induce one and for
people who use screen layers
it can be practically impossible
listen to the content of the page
when at the same time all these
videos are playing because the
script well is talking the videos
are playing and it is very difficult to
hear what is happening on
the page
and additionally all content like
video chips and animations  They need a
switch prepared, they have to make the
user's decision and if they want to
see what is happening on the page and
so if good, not force them to play
these videos automatically when
these animations were infinite.
Lastly,
since you are in the automatic tests, you can
make yourself automatic for the  accessibility
but they are not enough there is nothing
better than a manual test we can
do it now with all this
knowledge that you can go and do
tomorrow and do it on your page or on your
product and today listen we listen on
our website in more they have the voice
now
in windows you can download a twitter script
you have a chrome extension
called chrome voice which is also an
ereader and you can use it and see how
many of your page to see if it is
understandable to see if what
the screen reader is saying is logical  and there to start
how to have a sense how it is for
a person to listen to the pages and the
products another advice is to forget to
disconnect it disable your
trackpad and start using everything with
the keyboard I am going to make each of the
elements that can be accessible with
the most yes yes perfect but if not we already have to
fix
and at the end of all this and all this
talk 15 benefits for
accessibility well I would all of
us will all benefit at some point
in our lives and with this I am no longer with you
saying take all your product and
throw away the trash because it is inaccessible I
am not telling you that all these things
that they do to me are super small things
that do not take a lot of time and yet
they are on the web they are almost everywhere
out there it causes me a lot
annoyance many people that is to say
that small changes can have a
big impact changing all these things
can help many many people
but this is all it does not end in having
our html structure it does not end in
improving the colors there are many
more things that could be here talking about the
three hours on everything we can
do to improve the wada but these
are certain super small things that we
all have the possibility
and my last advice to all of us
is to get out of our houses and
start seeing the world from other
perspectives diversify your team
contracts people  with disabilities as
tests with real people and seek
different points of view learn from
each other's experiences and bring all
this knowledge and all these
new things to the one we are waiting for because
I believe that if we all put our bit
together we can make the  web
a more accessible and inclusive place
where we are all welcome
thanks this link is the repo link